[Applaus]
vor der tour
de sol riesenrad ist nichts für
weicheier
aber gott sei dank sind mir mehr so ort
gekocht
du wirst uns überhaupt nichts jetzt vor
mit der geisterbahn
da kann ich wieder die ganze nacht nicht
schlafen
bis ziemlich grüne kriegt mit pixie
wusste
hinschauen
[Gelächter]
ich esse
dann du musst gehen wurstsemmel stand
sagte peter kenny panik komme es im
griff jetzt da
horchen pass auf was du haben für
wurscht
das ist unsere spezialität galaxie
max wurst gut mein bicsi also machen wir
so bled wirklich durch immerhin das wort
hält dass er total
wurscht city die wurst ist
genau die nach fisch ist die loks musst
du ein
bus ist ist noch wo steht die
garnelen das land ist chloe wienerli
ja genau ich habe es voll drauf
geschrieben eigentlich muss da stehen
kleine wiener
legst du das geschäft des lebens fünf
euro
gestimmt
schamlos so gibt er
in der rosa vogel dort bei den herren
und
löffel auf empfang
ist kostenlos
der flamingo den kann man nicht kaufen
müssen schließen müssen weil kommen wir
gerne schießbude das ist eine schießbude
ja ich sie geschrieben dies fragt man
den song heißt im humidor war schon zum
[Gelächter]
18 euro zehn schuss ins schwarze zehn
schuss ins schwarze das werden wir wohl
hegering zehn euro so bekommen wir diese
herde ist dies für die so
[Gelächter]
braucht
willst du hast du spezi tricky ob du
bist wie hau den lukas scepanik
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
musst
du dass du dich besser kommt die spesen
kommt sowieso draufhaut da muss ich ganz
vorsichtig drauf fahren weil sonst
harting kosten immer mitte auseinander
was kosten trägt ein 5 1 55 war er fünf
verträgt
so oder so es würde ihn links den rotter
ja so und jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen
zurücktreten wird gewiss gerät in die
umlaufbahn
[Musik]
was versteht sich dies heißt dass der
schmuck unter der wahrnehmungsgrenze war
[Gelächter]
wird wird alles klar man muss dieses
gerät jetzt den weg der schmerzen
jetzt
schreiben
[Gelächter]
die christen ist
dieser voll kaputt ist ist echt verfalle
ich den kaffee wird sie richtig sagen
was kaputt ist nicht kaputt ist
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der apparat ist kaputt
ja entweder die savings portal oder ich
bin vielleicht wirklich stärker wird
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]